I started to introduce all those topics because I was trying to address the
issue of how it is that we've come to deal with the fact that things are so
complex that we can't deal with them and so a huge part of the answer to that is
the Darwinian answers.
One is while you keep up with things you can't keep up with by changing
unpredictably.
So here's an example.
You know sometimes if you're driving down the road and there's a deer on the
road,
maybe you'll run into it and it'll instead of jumping out of the way,
it sort of jumps randomly and then you run into it.
You think,
well that's a pretty stupid strategy.
It's like natural selection at work there,
but it turns out that deer jump randomly when wolves are chasing them.
Well,
why would you do that?
because you can't predict it,
right?
If,
if something horrible is after you acting unpredictably is actually a pretty
good strategy and that's basically what mutation does means.
The horrible thing that's after you always is the rapid transformation of the
environment and the only thing you can possibly do in that in that case is
capitalize on chance.
Okay,
so that's one thing.
So that's partly why the Darwinian story I think has to be right,
because the environment does move unpredictably and the only way you can keep up
with something that's unpredictable,
to generate variance and hope that one of them has drawn the lucky lottery card,
but then there's these additional issues which is that we're also.
We also seem to be tightly selected for the capacity to cooperate and compete.
So that multiplies our cognitive ability.
That's a huge part of it.
And then we're also.
We also seem to have constructed ourselves,
so to speak,
through sexual choice into these general problem,
general purpose,
problem solving creatures.
And so we've internalized some of the Darwinian process.
So you think,
well,
most animals will produce a variance of themselves physically and then most of
those variants die,
but human beings have built A.
Lance built a mechanism,
let's say that's like a game engine.
I think that's a really good.
You know how there are game engines now that people have devised their,
their computational devices and you can take a game engine and you can generate
games with it like computer games.
So I'm the game engine is a mechanism for producing games.
Well,
that's what our brains are like.
Our brains are game engines for producing games and so what happens is that when
you think you produce an Avatar of yourself,
you produce a fictional world and that that Avatar and habits and maybe you
produce multiple fictional worlds in multiple avatars,
that's the EU that could be tomorrow,
which is what you're doing when you're planning and you walk the Avatar through
its potential routes and those that look good and you keep and those that don't
look good,
you kill and so you can.
Then you can embody the ideas that you keep an act those out and hopefully the
idea is that when you embody them,
you're successful and you don't get killed.
And so we're select.
We've also seen that when we've been selecting each other for cognitive prowess,
we've been selecting ourselves for the ability to generate avatars out of
ourself and kill them instead of dying.
It's unbelievably brilliant.
And,
and that's really akin to the human discovery of the future.
Right?
The future is a place where variance of you could exist.
It's something like that and other animals don't seem to be able to do that.
So we're very sneaky.
And while so far doesn't seem to be working too badly,
although we haven't been around for very long,
right?
I mean human beings of our particular sub species about 150,000 years,
something like that,
which is from an evolutionary timeframe.
It's like it's nothing,
you know,
it's 2080 year old man.
It's not very long,
you know,
if you think about it that way.
Okay.
So
now what I want to do is draw a relationship between that developmental process,
that evolutionary process and the emergence of these underlying motivational
systems.
It's something like this.
So you imagine you go back in time to the emergence of the development of
nervous systems.
So there's cells that creatures use to do produce motor output,
and there are cells that creatures use to map the patterns around them onto
themselves.
And so those are that sensory.
That's the sensory layer,
so to speak.
Imagine sensory layer,
nervous layer,
motor layer.
In simpler animals,
you just have sensory motor cells.
Then they diversify sensory layer,
nervous layer,
motor layer.
In fact,
that's actually what you consist of when you're first developing in utero.
After the blast site stage,
when your cells differentiate,
that's the differentiation.
Sensory layer,
nervous layer,
motor layer.
So then you think there's a sensory layer.
Now what's that sensory layer doing?
Think about the world as consists consisting of patterns of all sorts,
like maybe there's an animal in the ocean and it's being subjected to wave
motion,
and so it's sensory systems map the wave motion onto the motor output.
So if you look at a sponge,
for example,
sponges are good examples because they're sort of half unicellular animals and
half multicellular animals.
You can take a sponge and run it through a colander and separate it out into
cells,
say in salt water,
and it'll assemble itself back into a sponge.
So it sort of at the.
Yeah,
amazing.
Hey,
it's kind of what you do in Utero.
It sells somehow know enough to communicate with another to one another to
organize themselves into an organism's.
It's unbelievable.
We have no idea how people do that because when you're in the initial form blast
site form,
all those cells are identical genetically and then all of a sudden they
differentiate and they moved other places they're supposed to go.
We have no idea how that.
How the hell can that happen?
These cells,
they're all identical except for their position,
so they're obviously communicating with one another in some unbelievably
complicated way and saying,
well,
you know this sort of sell it and so you're going to differentiate that way.
God only knows,
but anyway,
sponges can do this.
Now,
a sponge isn't complicated enough to have the sensory layer and the service
layer and the motor layer.
It's just sensory motor cells,
if I remember correctly,
but what the sponge is trying to figure out is it wants to get water through its
pores inside because that's how it eats and so there's wave motion constantly
and so what's happening is the wave motion is a pattern and the sponges reacting
to that in a patterned way and that's a really.
It's really useful to think about what you're responding to as patterns instead
of objects because we think we react to objects,
but objects are actually a specific subcategory of pattern and so because they
don't also helps to explain perception.
It's like,
well,
what does it mean for you to see something?
Well,
it means a bunch of things,
but one of the things that means is when I look at that thing,
it manifests itself to me as a grippable object.
I mean that that's built into the way I see it.
So if you think about the way that you see that on the surface there,
you can tell that it's separate from the surface because it has a bit of a
shadow and it's a different color and it's obviously shaped for a hand and so
that thing tells you when you look at it that it's the grabbable object.
Well it's,
it's hand shaped like a stone tool would be and so and all the things around you
in the world manifest themselves as patterns of utility that that's the
appropriate way to think about it.
You say,
well,
what does this thing mean?
Because that's a hard question.
Well,
one of the things that your eyes do,
it's like,
imagine you've got this representational surface at the back of your retina.
It's made out of pixels,
roughly speaking,
right?
Those are the cells and what it does is map that pattern onto your retinal
pattern and then the retinal pattern propagates itself as a nervous pattern
loan.
Your optic nerve.
And then that manifests itself as a neurological pattern and that neurological
pattern manifests itself as an action pattern.
And so the meaning of the object is the action pattern that is mapped onto the,
onto the percept.
And so what does this mean?
This is what it means.
I think this is a Piagetian observation.
It's like wonder many
one,
right?
Because I'm acting like it's one,
but if I do this
then it's many y one,
two,
right there separately manipulable entities.
And so the concept of number is in fact predicated,
at least in part
on the idea of singular usability.
But you're mapping.
It's like,
well what is this?
It's a key.
Well,
what does that mean?
I mapping that shape into this motion for that action say,
well,
it's not just a key,
it's a weapon,
right?
And so that's because I've mapped it onto a different output pattern.
But if you think about perception as the matching of patterns onto patterns,
it makes,
it makes way more sense.
You can really start thinking about how perception works,
because then you can also start thinking about unconscious perception.
So you know the,
the blind sight experiments show for example,
that if,
if you've had cortical damage,
so you think you're blind,
you can't see objects anymore,
but I show you a picture of a frightened face,
you'll show us in skin conductance response to it and you think,
well,
how the hell can that happen?
It's like I have to see the face in order to infer the emotion in order to have
the reaction.
It's like,
no,
you don't.
You don't need that at all.
You need a pattern recognition system that maps that right onto an amygdala
output that produces physiological readiness.
You don't need the perceptible entity because you know,
you think you see something and then you think about the thing and then you
evaluate the thing and then you act.
It's like you do do that.
But there are parts of you that don't do that at all.
Way Faster parts,
more primordial parts.
And so another example would be Darwin's trick with the snake that I told you
about.
He'd go to this museum that had a cobra in a glass cage and the Cobra,
he'd put his face up to the glass cage and the Cobra would strike out him and
he'd go like this,
and there was no way he could control that.
Well,
it's because the part of him that saw the snake wasn't the part that was doing
this.
There's a part of him that does this to snakes.
That's what it does and it's.
It's way faster than the per unit figure,
the to see the snake you have to the images.
Obviously the image,
the pattern is portrayed on the retina propagates backwards to see it.
It has to be elaborated up through a very complex set of neurological
connections that takes time.
And so your dad.
Well,
the thing that snake means this,
that's like three neurons super fast and so what is a snake at that level of
representation?
It's like a snake is that which makes you do this and then you could also say
that at that level of representation,
everything that makes you do this is the same thing,
right?
Because the same would be defined by the pattern that you manifest in response
to that entity,
so then your nervous system is layered very,
very sensory layer neurological layer,
motor layer.
As you become more complex,
the sensory layer differentiates into the different sensory systems and the
neurological level multiplies in terms of its potential number of connections.
So what happens is that you can map patterns that manifest themselves in
multiple different ways,
in multiple different ways to multiple motor outputs.
So you start with a fixed action pattern,
which is just like this.
The the sponge reflects what's the world to a sponge.
The world is what makes you go like this or like that.
That's it.
That's the whole world.
The sponge has compressed the entire world into pores,
open pores closed.
That's,
that's it to states.
And then once the nervous system gets differentiated and the senses get
differentiated,
so there's specialized kinds of cells,
then you can detect more forms of patterns.
You can produce more patterned output to that,
but even more interestingly,
and this is where the nervous system starts to come into play,
the mapping of the pattern onto the output is no longer one to one.
You can use the same pattern roughly speaking to British,
all sorts of different outputs that are context dependent because you might say,
well,
so okay,
I picked that up and you say,
well,
he picked that up.
It's okay.
Well what about that?
You think,
well,
he picked it up.
Well,
yeah,
I did.
Except that the pattern of musculature that I used to do this is by no means
identical to the pattern of musculature that I used to do that.
Right?
I mean the fact that the orientation is different is actually extraordinarily
important.
So,
so.
Well,
my point is,
is that right?
We're sufficient nervous complexity.
You can take the same thing,
so to speak and map it all sorts of different ways and human beings are
unbelievably good at that.
Okay,
so now go back to when things were simple.
So there's single celled organisms will say,
and then they start to differentiate to some degree and they start to propagate
and so then there's the environment starts to shift because the fact of the
prevalence of all of these competitors means the environment isn't exactly the
same as it was when that system first evolved,
new problems emerge and so then there's selection pressure on those creatures to
diversify to some degree and then the diversification produces a transformation
in the environment and then there's pressure on those new entities to diversify
some more.
And so you get this weird bootstrapping process.
Maybe the environment is one thing when there's 10 of you,
but a completely different thing when there's a thousand of you.
Right?
So just sheer multiplication is going to transform the environment.
And so then the.
Because the environment has now become more complex than it was their selection
pressure to produce diversification in the underlying organisms.
And that took a long time to get off the ground.
Like there were single celled organisms for a huge span of history.
I mean,
if you look at evolutionary history,
the amount of time that there were single celled organisms is far longer than
the time that there's been since the remotely celled organisms.
It's like it's like Moore's law.
You know the law that governs the,
the increase in computational power.
You can trace that back to about the year $1,400,
something like that.
So it's been going on for a very long time and maybe you could make the same
case from an evolutionary perspective.
It's like the flat part of the curve is really long,
but once it starts to move up,
it starts to move up really fast and obviously that's the position that we're in
now.
So single celled organisms for a long time.
Then they started to diversify and then you could imagine,
well
from the single cell organism,
you start getting multicellular organism and then it ends up with this
tripartite structure,
sensory layer,
nervous layer,
motor layer,
and then that starts to differentiate and every time there's a differentiation
that's conserved and that's these systems.
The motivational systems.
He emerged a long,
long time ago as emergent solutions to emergent problems and you've conserved
all of them.
I mean you've conserved your snake reflex,
which is like three neurons long,
so that's really,
really primordial,
but you've conserved,
you've conserved function at almost every temporal level,
so there's parts of you that are quick and dirty and parts of you that are slow
and sophisticated and a lot of the contents of consciousness is slow and
sophisticated,
so it can't help you out in an emergency,
but it can do or consciousness seems to do is take your structure,
it analyzes the world's for,
for let's say,
mismatches between what you want and what's happening,
and then it either helps you alter the world so those mismatches go away or it
turns inward.
Ma modifies the structures that you're using.
So if you're playing the piano,
you've got this automatized routine has very little to do with consciousness.
If you've practiced enough and you make a mistake,
you stop and you note the mistake,
you stop and then you slow it down and then you read.
You practice the new thing.
Then you speed it up.
Then you speed it up,
then you speed it up and as you're doing that,
the neural representation shrinks until you've developed this little specialized
machine and then you run that a few times and now you can ignore it.
You can look at the notes and just play and away you go,
and that's kind of what consciousness is doing all the time.
You're laying out an automatized routine and then if,
if that doesn't produce the intended outcome,
you stop.
You become conscious really because nothing like an error to make you conscious.
Then you do a high resolution analysis of the space in which the error emerged.
You rematch your motor output,
your perceptions and all of that to make that error go away in a way you go and
so your consciousness is continually.
Your consciousness seems to be continually building your unconscious,
your procedural unconscious,
and so to some degree,
the purpose of consciousness is to make you functional unconsciously,
right?
Because that's way better.
You don't want to be conscious if most things because it's just,
what are you going to do?
Be Conscious of your digestive processes.
It's like,
no,
if you're good at something,
you hardly have to be conscious of it at all.
So.